economía en directo américa de france 24
me acompaña en el estudio daniel
hablando nuevamente daniela vamos a
hablar de qué pasa en noruega porque
iniciaron la huelga de trabajadores de
petróleo y gas así es raúl pues el paro
lo protagonista un grupo de empleados de
la industria de alta mar que exige
aumentos salariales para compensar el
alza de los precios de la canasta
familiar
el operador local equinos inició el
cierre entonces de tres campos en el mar
del norte como resultado de esta huelga
algo que produce que reducirá la
producción de petróleo y gas e
incrementa los temores sobre una escasez
en europa ya que noruega es el segundo
proveedor de gas después de rusia si
esta huelga se llegar a extender hasta
el sábado la agencia especializada
reuters calcula que podría salir del
mercado casi un 60 por ciento de la
producción de gas noruega complicando
todavía más el panorama de precios en
este continente
bueno danny cómo se comporta el mercado
en argentina tras la preposición de la
nueva ministra de economía bueno
juramento entonces silvina batakis y
esto es
ella es vista como una cuota del
kirchnerismo en el gabinete de alberto
fernández los mercados reaccionaron de
la siguiente manera el principal índice
de la bolsa de buenos aires bajó más del
1 por ciento el precio del dólar oficial
alcanzó un nuevo máximo de 131,5 pesos
por unidad para la venta como también lo
hizo en el mercado informal hasta un
nivel nunca visto de 260 pesos mientras
que los títulos de deuda pública
nacional también se derrumbaron esto
pasa porque en medio de la incertidumbre
los inversionistas se deshacen de sus
activos argentinos y se refugian en el
dólar por eso ordenar sube y una gigante
del desayuno perdió una batalla legal en
el reino unido se trata de la
multinacional estadounidense que lo que
pretendía bloquear por medio de la
justicia una medida británica contra la
obesidad que prohíbe desde octubre o
prohibió desde octubre pasado la
promoción de cereales azucarados y otros
alimentos altos en grasa azúcar o sal la
dueña de marcas como su caritas choco
krispis y sus homólogas en el resto del
mundo como el rice krispies
o frosted flakes argumentó ante el
tribunal superior londinense que al
momento de emitir la norma no se tuvo en
cuenta el valor nutricional de la leche
que se le añade al cereal el juez
respondió que los señores mezclar un
cereal con leche no cambia el hecho de
que éste tiene un alto contenido de
azúcar la ley prohíbe que los alimentos
poco saludables estén ubicados en
estanterías de alto perfil en
supermercados como entradas o también en
los extremos de los pasillos entre otros
y el próximo año se van a endurecer
todavía más raúl por ejemplo se van a
prohibir las promociones de compre uno y
lleve dos y daniela se dejan y se le
meta de producción petrolera en ecuador
con el ministerio de minas y energía
reconoció que este objetivo de duplicar
la producción actual de 500 mil barriles
para 2025 va a tener un retraso debido a
los compromisos adquiridos para levantar
las recientes protestas de grupos
indígenas que incluyeron la derogatoria
de un decreto que promovía precisamente
la actividad petrolera
efectivamente va a haber un retraso
porque tendremos que ir realizando el
tema por tema
porque debemos de cumplir el compromiso
es posible que esta meta se pueda
generar en un poco más de años sin
embargo nuestra búsqueda es incrementar
la producción de forma sostenible o sea
lo que hemos hecho nosotros es trabajar
de forma sostenible danielle indicadores
económicos o street abrió hace pocos
minutos con fuertes descensos tras
volver del día festivo del 4 de julio
con los índices dow jones y nasdaq
cayendo casi un 2% descensos también
marcados en las bolsas europeas después
de que el euro se hundiera a un mínimo
de dos décadas frente al dólar en
particular esto se debe a la huelga de
trabajadores petroleros noruegos que
hizo que los precios mayoristas para
entrega diaria en londres se dispararan
casi un 16% el martes a media jornada y
las bolsas asiáticas cerraron mixtas en
medio de la incertidumbre mundial la
agencia internacional de energía dijo
este martes que los altos precios del
gas y los temores sobre el suministro
van a paralizar la actividad económica y
ralentizar de paso el crecimiento de la
demanda en los próximos años danny como
siempre gracias por toda la información
económica mañana nos vemos con más
economía
américa nos vamos directo hasta parís